judge I want to tell you something I
want to tell you something I've been
watching you and you're not two-faced it
you treat everybody the same that was
said to me by a transgender prostitute
who before I had gotten on the bench had
fired a public defender insulted the
court officer and yelled that the person
sitting next to her I don't know what
you're looking at I look better than the
girl you're with she said this to me
after I said her male name low enough so
that it could be picked up by the record
but I said her female name loud enough
so that she could walk down the aisle
towards counsels table with dignity this
is procedural justice also known as
procedural fairness at its best you see
I am the daughter of an african-american
garbageman
who was born in Harlem and spent his
summers in the segregated south soil a
haruna palooka dominicana
I do that to make sure you're still
paying attention I'm the daughter of a
Dominican beautician who came to this
country for a better life for her unborn
children my parents taught me you treat
everyone you meet with dignity and
respect no matter how they look no
matter how they dress no matter how they
spoke you see the principles of fairness
were taught to me at an early age and
unbeknownst to me it would be the most
important lesson that I carried with me
to the North Municipal Court bench and
because I was dragged off the playground
at the early age of ten to translate for
family members as they begged began to
migrate to the United States
I understand how daunting it can be for
a person and novice to navigate any
government system every day across
America and around the globe people
encounter our courts and it is a place
that is foreign intimidating and often
hostile towards them they are confused
about the nature of their charges
annoyed about their
counters with the police and facing
consequences that might impact their
relationships their finances and even
their liberty let me paint a picture for
you of what it's like for the average
person who encounters our courts first
they're annoyed as they're probed going
through court security they finally get
through court security they walk around
the building they ask different people
the same question and get different
answers when they finally get to where
they're supposed to be it gets really
bad when they encounter the courts what
would you think if I told you that you
could improve people's court experience
increase their compliance with the law
and court orders all the while
increasing the public's trust in the
justice system with a simple idea
well that simple idea is procedural
justice and if the concept that says
that if people perceive they are treated
fairly and with dignity and respect
they'll obey the law well that's what
Yale professor Tom Tyler found when he
began to study as far back as in the 70s
why people obey the law he found that if
people see the justice system as a
legitimate authority to impose rules and
regulations they would follow them his
research concluded that people would be
satisfied with the judges rulings even
when the judge ruled against them if
they perceived that they were treated
fairly and with dignity and respect
and that perception of fairness begins
with what begins with how judges speak
to court participants now being a judge
is sometimes like having a reserved seat
to a tragic reality show that has no
commercial interruptions and no season
finale it's true people come before me
handcuffed drugged sick depressed hungry
mentally and mentally ill when I saw
that their need for help was greater
than my fear of appearing vulnerable on
the bench
I realize that not only did I need to do
something but that in fact I could do
something the good news is is that the
principles of procedural justice are
easy and can be implemented as quickly
as tomorrow the even better news is that
it can be done for free the first
principle is voice give people an
opportunity to speak even when you're
not going to let them speak explain it
sir I'm not letting you speak right now
you don't have an attorney I don't want
you to say anything that's gonna hurt
your case for me assigning essays to
defendants has been a tremendous way of
giving them voice I recently gave an 18
year old college student an essay he
lamented his underage drinking charge as
he stood before me reading his essay his
voice cracking and his hands trembling
he said that he worried that he had
become an alcoholic like his mom who had
died a couple of months prior due to
alcohol-related liver disease
you see assigning a letter to my father
a letter to my son if I knew then what I
know now if I believed one positive
thing about myself how would my life be
different gives the person an
opportunity to be introspective go on
the inside which is where all the
answers are anyway but it also gives
them an opportunity to share something
with the court that goes beyond their
criminal record and their charges the
next principle is neutrality when
increasing public trust in the justice
system neutrality is paramount the judge
cannot be perceived to be favoring one
side over the other the judge has to
make a conscious decision not to say
things like my officer my prosecutor my
defense attorney and this is challenging
when we work in environments where you
have people assigned to your courts the
same people coming in and out of your
courts as well when I think of
neutrality I'm reminded of when I was a
new Rutgers law grad and freshly-minted
attorney and I entered an arbitration
and I was greeted by two gray-haired men
who were joking about the last game of
golf they played together and planning
social outings I knew my client couldn't
get a fair shot in that forum the next
principle is understand it is critical
that court participants understand the
process consequences of the process and
what's expected of them I like to say
that legalese is the language we use to
confuse I am keenly aware that the
people who appear before me many of them
have very little education and English
is often their second language so I
speak plain English in court a great
example of this was when I was a young
judge you know I mean younger judge when
I was a younger judge a senior judge
comes to me gives me a script and says
if you think somebody has mental health
issues ask them these questions and then
you can get your evaluation so the first
time I saw someone who had what I
thought was a mental health issue I went
from a script and I started to ask
questions I'm sorry do you take psycho
hmmm psychotropic psychotropic
medication nope
sir have you treated with a psychiatrist
before nope but it was obvious that the
person was suffering from mental illness
one day my frustration I decided to
scrap the script and ask one question
ma'am do you take medication to clear
your mind
yeah judge I take halodule from
schizophrenia xanex for my anxiety the
question works even when it doesn't mr.
L do you take medication to clear your
mind no Josh I don't take no medication
to clear my mind I take medication to
stop the voices in my head but my mind
is fine you see once people understand
the question they can give you valuable
information that allows the court to
make meaningful decisions about the
cases that are before them the last
principle is respect that without it
none of the other principles can work
now respect can be as simple as good
afternoon sir
good morning ma'am it's looking the
person in the eye who's standing before
you especially when you're sentencing
them it's when I say I'm how you doing
today and what's going on with you and
not as a greeting but as someone whose
action
be interested in the response respect is
the difference between saying ma'am are
you having difficulty understanding the
information in the paperwork versus you
can read or write can't you when you
realize there's a literacy issue and the
good thing about respect is that is
contagious people see you being
respectful to other folks and they
impute that respect to themselves you
see that's what the transgender
prostitute was telling me I'm judging
you just as much as you think you may be
judging me now I am not telling you what
I think I am telling you what I have
lived using procedural justice to change
the culture at my courthouse and in the
courtroom after sitting comfortably for
seven months as a traffic court judge I
was advised that I was being moved to
the Criminal Court part to criminal
courtroom now I need you to understand
this was not good news it was not part
to was known as the worst courtroom in
the city some folks would even say in
the state it was a typical urban
courtroom with revolving-door justice
you know your regular lineup of
low-level offenders you know the
low-hanging fruit the drug-addicted
prostitute the mentally ill homeless
person with quality of life tickets the
high school dropout petty drug dealer
and the misguided young people you know
those folks doing a life sentence 30
days at a time
fortunately the City of Newark decided
that Newark is deserved better and they
partnered with the Center for Court
innovation and the New Jersey judiciary
to create Newark community solutions a
community court program that provided
alternative sanctions this means now a
judge can sentence a defendant
to punishment with assistance so a
defendant who would otherwise get a jail
sentence would now be able to get
individual counseling sessions group
counseling sessions as well as community
give back which is what we call
community service the only problem was
that this wonderful program was now
coming to Newark and was going to be
housed where part two criminal court
and the attitudes there were terrible
and the reason that the attitudes were
terrible there was because everyone who
was sent there understood they were
being sent there as punishment the
officers were facing disciplinary
actions at times the public defender and
prosecutor felt like they were doing a
30 day jail sentence on their rotation
the judges understood they were being
hazed just like a college sorority or
fraternity I was once told that an
attorney who worked there referred to
the defendants as the scum of the earth
and then had to represent them I would
hear things from folks like oh how could
you work with those people they're so
nasty
you're a judge not a social worker but
the reality is is that as a society we
criminalize social ills then send people
to a judge and say do something I
decided that I was going to lead by
example so my first foray into the
approach came when a 60
something-year-old man appeared before
me handcuffed his head was lowered and
his body was showing the signs of drug
withdrawal I asked him how long he had
been addicted and he said 30 years and I
asked him do you have any kids and he
said yeah I have a 32 year old son and I
said oh so you've never had the
opportunity to be a father to your son
because of your addiction he began to
cry I said you know what I'm gonna let
you go home and you'll come back in two
weeks and when you come back we'll give
you some assistance for your addiction
surprisingly two weeks passed and he was
sitting in the courtroom when he came up
he said judge I came back to court
because you showed me more love than I
had for myself and I thought my god he
heard love from the bench I could do
this all day because the reality is is
that when the court behaves differently
than naturally people respond
differently the court becomes a place
you can go to for assistance
like the 60 something-year-old
schizophrenic homeless woman who was in
distress and fighting with the voices in
her head and barges into court and
Springs judge I just came by to see how
you were doing I had been monitoring her
case for a couple of months her
compliance with
medication and had just closed out her
case a couple of weeks ago on this day
she needed help and she came to court
and after four hours of coaxing by the
judge the police officers and the staff
she is convinced to get into the
ambulance that will take her to the
crisis unit so that she can get her
medication people become connected to
their community when the court changes
like the 50-something year-old man who
told me community service was terrible
judge I had to clean the park and it was
full of empty heroin envelopes and the
kids had to play there as he wrung his
hands he confessed judge I realized that
it was my fault because I used that same
part to get high and before you sent me
there to do community service I had
never gone to the part when I wasn't
high so I never noticed the children
playing there every addict in the
courtroom lowered their head who better
to teach that lesson it helps the court
reset its relationship with the
community like with the 20-something
year old guy who gets a job interview
through the court program he gets a job
interview at an office cleaning company
and he comes back to court to proudly
say judge I even worked in my youth in
my suit after the interview because I
wanted the guy to see how bad I wanted
the job it's what happens when a person
in authority treats you with dignity and
respect
like the 40-something year old guy who
struts down the aisle and says judge do
you notice anything different and when I
look up he's pointing at his new teeth
that he was able to get after getting a
referral from the program but he was
able to get them to replace the old
teeth that he lost as a result of years
of heroin addiction when he looks in the
mirror now he sees somebody who's worth
saving you see I have a dream and that
dream is that judges will use these
tools to revolutionize the communities
that they serve now these tools are not
miracle cure-alls but they get us light
years closer to where we want to be and
where
wannabe is a place that people enter our
halls of justice and believe they will
be treated with dignity and respect and
know that justice will be served there
imagine that a simple idea thank you
[Applause]
[Music]